綺麗なのうわぁすげぇ
vision こちら外してそうです皆さんホットケーキ食べたことあります
ホット駅食べたことないとほぼいないと思うんですけどもみんなが食べてきたホット
ケーキってまま常識の範囲内で囚われているのが一般的に人は想像できないが最初の
この薄いほっときなと思うんですけどもなぁ品のグリーとグダってもありますからこの
ぐりとぐら猫に出てくるホットケーキっていうか捨てなきゃならねーか
をめっちゃ美味しいそうなやつがあるんですよね本当にも現実だとないようなこのアニ
メっていうか絵本の世界ならではの
こういう設計置きふっくらしたパンティーがあるんですけども
それがなんとこちら炊飯器で膨れるんです
ています
上
う
だけ製版機を使って作ることができるらしいですよ普通のホットケーキってなんか幸
薄いイメージの友ですけども
ちょっ製版機を使って作るとしてなんかもほんと安全に出てくるような
ブービーみたいなホットキーができるらしいんで早速作っていこうと思います a プロ
が全部東京においてきました
ではいこ
入って夕食デザインようでございます音がいろんな人がぐりとぐらのホットケーキ作っ
てるレシピがあるんですけどもねいいただ混ぜ合わせねぇかこれがいいんだろうな
みたいなやつをレビューで考えた奴を今日は紹介していきたいと思いますこちら
ホットケーキミックスたまご牛乳マヨネーズ
暴露クリームチーズ入り朝食いろんなサイトとか動画を地下パクリながらやっていき
ましょう
これで作っていきます第2部
たよね
だっていろんな1台複利型とかだしてから
うん大丈夫だけっていいかと思いますではまずは他の方にここに入れてきます
ああ今ちょっと混ぜていきましょう
よしや告げ牛中12大臣も気持ちも入れます
7 d か夏はないですねかちょっと3杯分わかんないんですけどた100ml とか
でいい気がします
でしっかり混ぜてきます
モーホー完成ですねそしてホットギミックいえできますもうちょっと僕らが言ってるか
わかんないんでなんか気持ちでみましょう
ほらっ
パール入り過ぎたらこんなもんでいっしょぜってー入りすぎたがこれ大丈夫か目
しっかり混ぜてきます
[音楽]
はなんかすげー重視さんよし ok ですだいぶ綺麗に
ございましたもしでよくわかんなきゃマネージャータブンネ隠し味みたいな感じだと
思うんだ
に入れます貼ったは違うなバダあったら最後に載せるんだろうな
この後に入れていいかわかんねーんだけど
わかんないけどを一層の熱水入れてみようっていう価格ですねこれ
[音楽]
もう良いのではないでしょうかこれで傷は完成です
いいなこれ
バカでも作れるなぁ簡単と言ってくれるんですけどでこれを防水ハンディセットして
ってこれだったたけだけです
はいこれでもう完成だって
料理をいうか
はいと夕食完成してるはずですこれで完成していなかったのに今日の方終わりたから
ないやばいまじでやばい俺でもこういう料理で何かこれ簡単ねほど失敗しやすいですよ
今だから成功しないと売って大倉はであるからつい
j
わー
いやー
どっちだこれどっくんとどっちなこれとどちらこれを成功がこれどっち立つよ俺
0終わって
絶海あっちゃい
手袋の意味バツ2分主のため月帰ってからが成功だと思うんでここからがポイントです
えっ
ちゃんと熱いなちゃんと明日いいよさあ
これで
あきたきたきたーんこちらを通した今絶対落ちた音ましたねこれでもう巡ったらても
ありますいきます
ん
普段食べた
いやたぁー
ああやったあーうーらー
すごいすごいすごいすごい寓意とフラッティ出てくるパンケーキやアニメは世界ですよ
これもうすぐるーーーー
エバーはっはー感動しすぎですね写真撮るねちょっと
いやーこれはすごいわ
[音楽]
はいという風で完成しました
ね嬉しいこんなにきれいにできるなりますもうネタこぎれいな感じどうもすっげー綺麗
な金がリターンそしてグラデーションでだんだん黄色くなって食ってこのアニメって
感じそしてこのぶっさあ絵バターまた
う
こら上だろうなあまあ
やべえはもう今後普通のホットキーて作れつをランナーこれがもう最高ですよきっと
食べてみようと思いますいただきます
わあああバターがと望むてきたらやってこれでおこげ人はすごく大事か本当にこんな
綺麗なことある
ああああああああ
名前だけだいただきます
うブームを
梅はあの皆さん味はそんな特に代わり映えないんです普通のホットケーキの味がします
ちょっと中身見てみたいで切ってみます
桃
どら焼きですねよそんなめちゃくちゃ熱が通ってないわけでもない普通に食べれると
思うんですけどこんな訴えホット景気がすごい贅沢ですね
[音楽]
ん
うん実はこれウ前はなんか一人暮らししてる男中でも作れるぐらいの
て壁さでした
グーン
ブーブーオーダー観念でなんで絶好や入るぐらいナーンねすっごい量多いなぁ
なんか友達とかみんなで食べる分にはいいかもしれないでちょっとは結ばちゃんの
一人暮らし用じゃない
あでもとっといえば次の日食べるとができると思うんですけど
一人暮らしの人も何か皆で食べるって言うのはありだと思うんで作ってみて下さいねあ
でも綺麗だーなぁ
ああああああ
人間も食べ物もまずは見た目う
あっハール helder